the minute tom moore gets anywhere near
buckingham palace he becomes a different
person
he's a professional prince william
double and it's not long before he's
besieged by throngs of royal fans
he looks like one of the
royal family i don't remember his name
yes
god recently married
two years ago now he has got son out
what he's doing here on the common road
is that really him
it's someone from the royal family yes
it's william
um
so can we make a video absolutely
yeah tom moore loves slipping into the
role of britain's heir to the throne
above all he sees himself as an
entertainer
i never get any negativity everybody
just thinks it's great and everyone
wants a picture i don't mind doing it
for as long as it happens
all the people you meet as well just
just from just making them laugh and
just giving them something to talk about
and lightening up their day
tom always keeps a keen eye on the
latest events in the life of his royal
role model so that his impersonation of
prince william remains as convincing as
possible
in the past he's spent hours in front of
the mirror perfecting prince william's
regal smile
he keeps his teeth together
and it's not a full-on smile it's kind
of a
it's a smile but it's not too too big
tom's career as a royal look-alike began
in 2005 when he won a competition for
royal family doubles
after his success his family convinced
him to apply to an agency
the first time i met him the first thing
i said was you look like prince william
um and then we've been out shopping and
people have stopped us
i think it's great that he's got this
opportunity it's something different
isn't it no it's fun
i am i get most of his wardrobe ready
i'm in the background
okay so um this is the shirt i'm going
to wear today um
this is the the casual look which he
does wear in the public quite a lot it's
more of the chino trouser with a light
blue shirt sometimes like striped that
is relaxed he's not too formal um he
come trying to come across as just an
everyday guy really
tom's public appearances are mostly for
corporate pr events and he often appears
along with a cape double
today he's with his favorite partner
heidi agan the two lookalikes have
studied and perfected every last
mannerism of the royal couple
we have to look at into each other's
eyes lovingly yes
tom moore and heidi argan are managed by
the susan scott's lookalikes agency
ever since william and kate's engagement
business has been booming
the number of prince william look-alikes
at the agency has rocketed from 20 to
60.
tom is one of the most popular
he looks good of course and i think as
well he's got a young child so he can
almost
you know he takes on that william role
he understands what it's like to have a
new child
tom's son ellis was born a year before
the royal baby prince george
in a couple of years time that you won't
notice your age difference so much so
you can get on a few jobs with daddy
yeah
i think you'll need to lose the curly
hair
um
but yeah if you look hopefully he looks
like me and therefore looks like george
so hopefully it will work
tom isn't planning to give up his
part-time job as a royal double ganger
anytime soon in fact he's already
looking forward to his first appearance
as king of england